like if Tom Brady and Wiz Khalifa could
be an athlete the idea of whiz is like
he's just smoking all day he's partying
he's doing whatever but like I've seen
whiz in a green room and this guy knows
exactly what he's doing he's polished
he's sharp business game on doing a
little research and I'm seeing you're
like you take a
great journalism everything I can do
that they can do the science behind and
see exactly kind of what I need to be
eating and what I need to be avoiding
I'm trying to be the best that I could
be and I believe if I'm the best that I
can be I can be the best to ever do it
and it does look like I just kind of
smoked weed don't do you know too much
stuff but that's part of the Art of War
yeah Charlemagne has probably said it a
million times
it's you know let your enemy think
you're an idiot you don't know when
they're going in the ring with you okay
you've been analyzing them dumps bro
yeah exactly